la liberté des uns s'arrête là où
commence celle des autres cet aphorisme
du philosophe anglais john stuart mill
prend tout son sens en cette période de
crise sanitaire
depuis le dernier déconfinement en
décembre 2020 les français sont soumis à
un couvre-feu
d'abord fixée à 20 heures puis avancez à
18h en premier lieu pour certains
départements puis à l'ensemble de la
france métropolitaine depuis le 16
janvier
lassé par cette mesure le pays a
néanmoins pour leur éviter un troisième
confinement ce dont se félicite des
pouvoirs publics ce qu'on a pu voir si
long silence et analyse en tenant compte
de la présence nous varions britannique
sur un territoire en france au début de
l'année est issu des estimations de la
première enquête flèche que ces cours un
peu anticipée a eu un impact
considérable sur la sur les reculs des
la souche historique pour évaluer
l'efficacité du couvre-feu santé
publique france a scindé le territoire
en trois catégories
vous le voyez est ces groupes sont
répartis selon la date d'instauration du
couvre feu
selon le dernier bilan de santé publique
france les chiffres sont plutôt bons et
le taux d'incidence globalement
stabilisé en métropole
sur l'ensemble du territoire les taux de
positivité sont en baisse sur les trois
groupes
mais le nombre de nouveaux cas a diminué
de seulement 9% passant à une moyenne
d'environ 20000 cas par jour
des chiffres encourageants mais qui
restent très éloignées des objectifs
annoncés lors du deuxième confinement et
des 5000 cas par jour voulu par emmanuel
macron si le nombre de contaminations
demeure en dessous de 5000 cas par jour
les salles de sport et les restaurants
pourront couvrir et le couvre-feu pourra
être décalée en cause l'arrivée
progressive sur le territoire des
variants lesquels pourraient fortement
contrecarrer cette mesure à terme rien
ne laisse donc présager un allègement
des restrictions puisque aucun objectif
n'a pour l'instant été fixée par
l'exécutif et du côté de l'opposition on
commence à s'agacer plus que
sérieusement de cette situation on a eu
l'habitude de l'état d'urgence pour des
questions de terrorisme qui a été
inscrit directement dans la loi
finalement
dans un état d'urgence permanent et pour
nous c'est extrêmement problématique
parce que c'est liberticide et que
surtout ça donne les pleins pouvoirs à
l'exécutif et je crois que au contraire
on aurait besoin d'avoir beaucoup plus
de démocratie sanitaire de démocratie
aux pandémies et choisissent de le faire
par l'autoritarisme le conseil de
défense et un président de la république
qui décide seul
je crois que c'est une très très
mauvaise solution que ce qu'ils font un
homme seul décide de mesures privatives
de liberté
c'est pas un état d'urgence sanitaire
par hasard c'est qu'on oblige les gens à
rentrer chez eux à 18h et que c'est pas
ratifié par le parlement en angleterre
en israël le parlement décide là c'est
fini c'est un suicide du parlement vous
l'aurez compris la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire valises cette
mesure dénoncée comme liberticide voir
anticonstitutionnelle par certains
politologues l'état d'urgence ou non
nous restons dans un état de droit les
citoyens peuvent tout à fait saisir le
conseil d'état concernant la mesure de
couvre feu ou le conseil constitutionnel
concernant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
ces deux instances doivent alors évalué
la proportionnalité des mesures au vue
de la situation sanitaire
alors quand pourra-t-on retrouver ne
serait ce qu'un semblant de vie normale
c'est toute la question et nous sommes
nombreux à nous la poser car le temps
commence à devenir non les jours aussi
avec l'arrivée prochaine à du printemps
les solutions s'amenuisent pour
l'exécutif qui doit jongler entre une
pression hospitalière constante et des
dénonciation d'atteintes aux libertés
fondamentales de plus en plus fréquentes
le tout alors que la présidentielle aura
lieu dans quinze mois